why do people go to church
right because that's what's going on why
should they because that's a discussion
so jonathan took me to an orthodox uh
um
uh
ceremony in seattle and uh
like i wasn't into it um i i i found it
it grated on me um you're like a 10 year
old boy that we're telling to stop
moving yeah yeah that's right so that
was my freudian fixations like you're a
tan
wiggly yeah yeah stop wiggling no
kidding
no kidding but um you know there's been
a lot of water under the bridge since
then man and i went to an orthodox uh uh
mass here a couple of weeks ago and i
found it unbel and a catholic one a week
before that i was down at uh franciscan
university and i found it unbelievably
soothing which is very much unlike the
reactions i've had before and that was
partly well for complicated reasons
because i actually find any place that
isn't a bloody nightmarish catastrophe
soothing now
and so
i mean that man and but there was more
to it than that too it was because i i
also did develop and partly as a
consequence of our discussions a deeper
appreciation for
what was happening in the ritual itself
and
and also more tolerance for whatever
inadequacies i might perceive you know
partly that's also realization you know
lots of modern people say why don't go
to church because i don't believe that
it's like
well a who cares what you believe like
who the hell are you anyways
like and why do you even care what you
believe and how is that working for you
this belief set that you theoretically
have is how sophisticated is that like
you are you plato or what it's like well
here's the church and here's me and i'm
right it's like well no you're not and
first and second you don't even want to
be because that's a great place to be
like pinnacle of brilliant wisdom it's
completely solipsistic no tradition for
me thank you very much you know i've got
it all right in my head and even if you
are right that the bloody institution is
chaotic and
and and and uh
decadent in some fundamental sense it's
like well good there's something for you
to do like there always has been
throughout the entire history of mankind
because that's osiris right the the once
great king who's fallen into disrepair
it's like well if the church is broken
and you're the genius to see it why do
you go fix it well then you might say
well we'll just abandon it it's like
okay well
fine you're gonna get rid of that you're
gonna get rid of marriage you're gonna
get rid of funerals you're gonna get rid
of christmas you're gonna get rid of any
sense of sacred time you're gonna
dispense with the whole history of what
judeo-christian thought
you're going to dispense with the idea
of the sacred nature of the individual
like how far are you willing to go with
this and believe me that question is
right in front of you because there's a
wave of radicals who are asking you at
every moment
what makes you so sure that there's a
difference between a man and a woman
like
no there isn't or the yes there is when
we want there to be and no there isn't
when we don't want her to be you saw
that with the supreme court
appointment it's like we have to have a
woman
but there's no such thing as a woman
it's like
and so yeah
you
you frenchmen you know you've you've
abandoned your catholicism you think the
catholics they were crazy it's like you
ain't seen nothing yet
and so i'd believe and young kind of
convinced me of that he he more or less
posited and you could say the same thing
about orthodox he said catholic is as
insane as people ever get and that's
partly because we have to have one foot
in the dream
and the mystery we have to you know when
i heard douglas murray speak recently
about this that was very interesting
because murray
is an atheist essentially and he has a
variety of reasons for that
but he has swung around hard recently
and he said when he was talking to dave
rubin he said
i don't believe that either conservatism
or classic liberalism can survive in the
absence of the of the religious surround
which is really something for him to
admit and it's like taking him like five
years of thinking to come to that
conclusion but then he said something
even more remarkable i thought and he
said and it's actually the mysterious
part of it that has to be retained the
virgin birth the resurrection the
crucifixion all of that crazy mythology
let's say
because otherwise it just degenerates
into another
form of cheap social justice and like
don't we have enough of that and i think
that's now i don't know what to make of
that because well and that's why we have
discussion continually about
the
what would you say
well the transcendent i suppose the
miraculous the transcendent the idea of
the resurrection for example and all of
that it's like well what do you do with
that and the answer is
we don't know but we don't throw it out
without
having some sense of what's going to
come in to replace it
and we're seeing that now you know look
at us we're so confused bloody one of
the russians are at war with us is like
we're not having anything to do those
people
they simultaneously proclaim that a
woman is absolutely necessary for the
highest position in the land or one of
them and that the same person says
well i don't even know what a woman is
it's like well are those people insane
it's like clearly
clearly that's just way too far right
when i talk to my democrat friends i say
look you can have one of those
you know there's either no distinction
between a man and a woman
or it's important that a woman's on the
supreme court but there's no bloody way
i'm giving you both
so because i don't even know how to do
that i have no idea how to do that like
what am i supposed to do celebrate
womanhood
and simultaneously celebrate the fact
that the differences between men and
women are so trivial that they're
irrelevant and they can be changed at
web that is insane it it violates the
law of non-contradiction and so
there's no
that's
you think religious people are crazy